[Musique]
ah la belle musique de synthétiseurs
comme ça vous allez mettre une petite
chanson dans l'hôtel 35 ans super mario
incroyable incroyable mais vrai marc
henri bléhaut la génération ma
génération
oui c'est un personnage pas on pourrait
lui-même une icône de la pop culture
et il est assurément aussi donc le
personnage le plus rentable de
l'histoire des jeux vidéo marc andré a
absolument et ça s'est passé à 35 ans
donc il est né en 1985 et les gens qui
achetaient la console nintendo à
l'époque que vous savez c'est ce qu'elle
lance est également aussi nintendo ça
ressemble à ça il y avait le jeu mario
bros il y avait d'autres ont également
de la chasse de canard et il y avait ce
fusil je suis convaincu que les gens la
maison vont aller voir ce que j'ai
encore ma console
si vous avez encore votre corps au sol
j'imagine ça vaut quand même de l'argent
et la première mouture ça ressemble à ça
c'est rudimentaire mais franchement 1985
c'était ultra sophistiqué macquarie
ultrasophistiqués sa révolutionner donc
les jeux vidéo et là vous le voyez
d'année en année on est rendu en 1990 on
l'a changé toutes sortes deux fois on le
mit en 2d on le mit à 3d et vous savez
c'est quoi le but de mario bros et mario
qui doit aller délivrer la princesse à
vous savez des jeux vidéo qui fonctionne
bien généralement le but de l'histoire
c'est assez simple et regardez je vais
préparer une petite animation il va
rentrer dans son tube 373 millions de
jeux qui ont été vendus des mario bros
depuis 1985 ce qui a fait le jeu le plus
populaire puis vous voyez aussi il ya
mario kart également ça c'est très
populaire même maintenant alors c'est
une course mario contre ses ennemis
luigi toad la princesse donkey kong est
rapidement seulement vous dire mario est
apparue en 1981
en fait faut dire il est juste ici vous
allez le voir c'était l'époque vous
savez des arcades
oui je le veux dire dans les bars entre
que si dans quelques années on
l'appelait à l'époque romane et
on devait ressembler c'est vous a pas
pareil mais donc les haillan à droite
papaye avait dit non et on n'est pas
question alors les japonais ont décidé
de faire ce personnage est seulement
regarder en terminant un jeu alors là la
cassette qui n'avait pas été déballé
marc-andré été vendus lors des derniers
jours 115 mille dollars mais n'étaient
pas des balles et c'est ça la différence
assez rare c'est une pièce de collection
parce qu'on prend merci